so in this video we're going to talk about
using iodine topical iodine for skin tags
now you can also use this for warts as well now
there's some real interesting data which i'll put
the links down below that shows that using topical
iodine can inactivate the papillomavirus which
is behind warts and skin tags now as far as the
relationship between this virus causing skin tags
they don't know this for a fact but i think that
this virus is behind skin tags simply because
skin tags respond to iodine topical iodine now
the type of iodine i would recommend for this
is povidone iodine it's an over-the-counter iodine
you can get it anywhere and you just put a little
drop on the skin tag and do that for several days
in a row you can put a little band-aid over it
and watch what happens now you can
also do the same thing with a wart
human papilloma viruses are the most common
sexually transmitted infection this virus is also
behind cervical cancer now because of the fact
that iodine is antibacterial antiviral anti-yeast
anti-fungal anti-mold it would make sense to
me that if you had enough iodine in your diet
that it could potentially help you reduce the risk
for some of these problems because what you have
to realize is that a lot of these viruses can go
in and out of remission they can stay dormant if
there's enough protection and trace minerals
like iodine is one way to keep these viruses
in the dormant remission stage and there's quite
a few other trace minerals that also will help
put viruses back in remission and zinc is also at
the top of the list now as far as warts and skin
tags i think it's a no-brainer to use a topical
iodine all right try it out and comment down below
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing
by to help you this is just for the
people in the u.s hopefully in the future
we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help